[Music]
hey guys it's justine and right now
we're at steve jobs theater and i'm so
excited because behind me is the new n2
macbook pro 13-inch and the all-new
macbook airs so this right here is the
new macbook pro this is the 13 inch and
this does have the m2 but this is pretty
much the same design as the m1 and it
even has the touch bar we've got our two
ports here and we also have our
headphone jack on the side and the one
thing that you will notice is this does
not have the magsafe whereas the new
macbook airs they do have the magsafe
the macbook air has the new unibody
design which kind of looks more like the
16 inch macbook whereas this one has the
sort of same finish as the previous
intel max and the previous 13 inch m1
but as far as like size goes i mean they
look pretty much actually like the same
size the air is definitely thinner and
the air no longer has kind of like that
slanted wedge design it's kind of like
the 16 inch macbook
just super squished and i love that this
is an all new unibody aluminum design
and the fact that they have mag safe now
is so exciting because previously you
would have two thunderbolt usb c ports
and you'd have to use one of those to
charge but now that magsafe is freeing
up a charging port so you'll have access
to both of the ports and not have to
worry about charging a little magsafe
got our two ports and our high impedance
headphone 3.5 millimeter jack and this
has
four new colors we have the silver
starlight
space gray in the midnight this midnight
is almost depending upon the light that
you're in like it looks like it's a
matte black so i think marquez may be
hyped about this it does have a little
hint of blue when you kind of move
around a little bit so depending upon
the light situation actually all of
these colors seem to sort of shift and
morph into something new and different
in each light setting something else
that i'm really excited about is these
matching braided cables that will match
the color of your macbook air now they
first did this in the colored imax and
that was probably one of my favorite
features so i'm really glad they decided
to carry this over so we have our
midnight here we have our
space gray
our starlight
and our silver i love that even these
little mag safe that is also matching
whatever the finish is so let's plug
these in shall we
i love this new charging brick it has
two ports so you can charge not only
your laptop you can charge your iphone
or something else that's usbc powered
and this is a 35 watt brick it's nice
flat super slim this will definitely be
going into my travel bag let's let's try
it out like look how good that's gonna
look
look at that this is what it would look
like
there's not actually something there so
i i just that's why my finger was on it
the new macbook airs have a starting
price of 11.99 and the macbook pro is
starting at 12.99 and it's kind of
incredible to think how far we've come
since the m1 which was maybe like two
years ago and the m1 has by far been
something that i've been so incredibly
impressed with and now that we're
upgrading to the m2 i can't wait to try
this i'm so excited let me know in the
comments below what you guys think i
would love to hear what is your favorite
color of the new macbook air thank you
guys for watching this is just a fun
first look at the new m2 macbooks i am
so excited i cannot wait to try these
out but this is a quick little first
look to show you guys what we can expect
in these new devices and with that i'll
see you guys in my next video don't
forget to subscribe
[Music]
you